[Música]
a
[Aplausos]
hola a todos
hoy les voy a hablar de economía un poco
nosotros como país el motor de nuestra
economía de la exportación a nuestras
materias primas oil exporta gas un poco
de petróleo soya minerales
estas materias primas exportamos a
países como china como alemania donde se
desarrollan celulares computadoras
refrigeradores y luego nos vuelven a
mandar
entonces este ciclo de vender barato y
comprar caro no es un país pobre
porque hay muchos estudios del banco
mundial de universidades del por qué
países como nosotros emergentes países
subdesarrollados tienen este problema
podemos hablar de motivación podemos
hablar de mala alimentación de que no
hemos intentado podemos hablar de que no
tenemos el know-how podemos hablar de
que nuestros gobernantes no lo hacen
bien y etcétera etcétera etcétera pero
realmente bastante nuestro no somos los
únicos si ustedes ven en la versión
ustedes no conocen un celular argentino
por ejemplo o tampoco un televisor
chileno o un automóvil brasilero
sin embargo son economías muchísimo más
grandes que las nuestras y aún así ellos
tampoco pueden producir este tipo de
cosas así que ese es un punto
interesante a evaluar
aquí les muestro 6 startups y tienen dos
puntos en común
el primer tema
es que todos valen más de mil millones
de dólares
todos mercado libre skype rap y
despegar.com lx newman y hay como estos
hay varios más y tienen otro punto en
común
todos son de países como el nuestro
países donde tampoco se desarrollan
celulares y automóviles y refrigeradores
sin embargo yo sí han podido hacer este
tipo de empresas de estas me interesan
más por sobre todo dos la primera es
mercado libre mercado libre vale 15 mil
millones de dólares y pf que es el
equivalente a ypfb de bolivia no que es
de argentina vale 8 mercadolibre una
empresa netamente digital vale casi el
doble de lo equivale la empresa estatal
más importante de argentina en el caso
de skype skate vale 8.5 billones es que
observe salgado en estonia en estonia
hay un millón de personas aquí somos 11
el pib de estonia es de 20 mil millones
de nuestros de casi 40 entonces si un
país como estonia puede producir un
skype que hoy día vale 8.5 millones
porque nosotros no
aquí les cuento un poco de bolivia y el
talento que existe en bolivia aquí
tenemos dos grandes empresas que muchos
las conocen una escala soft los tres
muchos son productoras de software a
nivel internacional para clientes
extremadamente prestigiosos como vip y
más está de l'oréal petrobras enormes
clientes con necesidades tecnológicas
extremadamente avanzadas y todo se hace
acá en bolivia que demuestra esto los
volvíamos tenemos un enorme talento
enorme
él está un poquito de otra casa que es
algo sencillo
antiguamente tú querías un inmueble tú
ibas al periódico tienes que recorrer te
todo el periódico ver cientos de
anuncios y hacer llamadas etcétera
etcétera y vas visitados en inmuebles y
usualmente o no te gustaba o no te
interesaba y así vas perdiendo tu tiempo
el tiempo del que vendía el único la
única innovación que hay otra casa es
que mejora este proceso otra casa éste
permite ver fotos ver una ubicación te
permite filtrar te permite ordenar y te
permite conversar directamente con el
vendedor entonces así evitas perder el
tiempo tuyo y el del vendedor es
sencillo y les soy franco no es muy
innovador
ultra casas deben haber en el orden de
2000 portales como entre casas en el
mundo el primero en otra casa se hizo el
92 nosotros desarrollamos nuestra casa
del 2015 así que unos 25 años de ventaja
nos llevaba
esta es la curva real de tráfico de
ultra casas
inicialmente otra casa tenía dos mil
visitas al mes que era más o menos entre
30 y 100 visitas al día hoy en nuestra
casa llega a casi 400 mil visitas
mensuales que tenemos picos de hasta 23
mil visitas diarias si tú ves nuestro
tráfico lo podemos distribuir en tres
fases simples la primera es creer que
sabes mucho
la segunda es mentor en la investigación
y la última es innovación nosotros como
otra casa hemos perdido tiempo dinero y
esfuerzo por un año y un poco más en
toda esa primera parte que ustedes ven
por el 2 de las 1 creíamos que sabíamos
lo que estamos haciendo cuando en verdad
no sabían absolutamente nada pero el
segundo tema importante es que no
tenemos a quien preguntar y les soy
franco bolivia no hay muchas personas
con las que puedes comenzar de este tipo
de cosas nuestro ecosistema es muy débil
a comparación de lo que hay en cualquier
otro país del mundo
entonces luego de casi cerrar un par de
veces decidimos salir a preguntar y aquí
eso nos empezó a poner interesante las
cosas
gracias a distintas suertes de haber
vivido afuera etcétera etcétera que
tenía amigos de harvard y stanford
amigos con horas muy exitosos en méxico
en eeuu y con ellos empezamos a
preguntar y preguntar y preguntar les
soy franco una charla de 20 minutos con
una persona que sabe vale más que una
maestría de dos años por simplemente
están respondo lo que quiere saber y eso
ocurrió y empezamos a crecer logramos
tener entrenamiento de un ex gerente de
google nueva york' y eso para nuestro
marketing digital fue extremadamente
importante y la curva empezó a crecer lo
interesante es que después de un tiempo
esas preguntas o esa enseñanza de
nuestros amigos se convirtió en una
conversación
ahora nosotros también entregamos algo a
la mesa ellos también nos preguntan a
nosotros es decir que logramos llevarnos
a un punto donde ya conocíamos casi lo
mismo y les soy franco hemos tenido unas
cuantas sorpresas interesantes que se
las voy a mostrar aquí en este punto es
cuando empezamos a innovar
empezamos a hacer cosas que portales
enormes en el mundo no lo habían hecho y
aquí es donde se empieza a poner aún más
interesante el tema
estos son algunos ejemplos que les voy a
contar como comentaba maurice es un rato
extrañamente si ustedes ven la evolución
de la comunicación entre personas tú
esperarías que primero era el mensaje
luego la llamada videollamada y la
realidad virtual y vamos a seguir ese
camino pero la sociedad no le gusta la
sociedad no le gusta porque es muy
intrusivo porque tú quieres en tu
privacidad así que el chat nos encanta
porque puedes pensar antes de escribir
es cómodo así que nos vamos quedando el
chat y nosotros sabíamos eso nuestra
casa queríamos hacer una forma que
nuestros clientes puedan chatear y
desarrollamos un chat interno y vemos
dos meses de desarrollo gastan plata a
tiempo y el chalet es más importante es
que sabíamos que las probabilidades de
que 10 millones de personas se bajen
nuestra aplicación para poder chatear
eran muy muy bajas y muy costosas
entonces estábamos en ese intento y
constantemente buscábamos whatsapp si
podíamos integrarnos si no se podían
hasta que whatsapp lanzó un pequeño link
y nos integramos en menos de tres días
fuimos el primer portal en el mundo que
nosotros conocíamos porque como les
comenté como 2000 nosotros revisamos
como 50 que tenía esto en el mundo hoy
día son más de 10 y le mostré esto al
cio de o lx o lx vale 1.5 millones de
dólares y el tipo se queda impactado a
lo que habíamos hecho y nos preguntó
cómo lo habíamos hecho
este es otro ejemplo que hicimos
desarrollamos un evaluador de mercado
donde tú conoces la oferta la demanda
inmobiliaria y le puedes predecir a un
proyecto qué tipo de mueble debería
construir un departamento de uno de dos
o de tres dormitorios es una herramienta
un poco simple en el concepto pero no
tan fácil de desarrollar le mostramos a
esta herramienta a un amigo que es el
hero flórez de ebay ebay ustedes medio
que conocen vale 40 mil millones de
dólares y las palabras de este amigo
fueron es como wow
pero en malas palabras argentino y el
fuego muy gratificante porque una
persona de semejante envergadura en todo
aspecto intelectual tipo es realmente
brillante se quedó muy impactado con lo
que los bolivianos estábamos haciendo
por último tenemos un amigo es un
francés se llama giles el fondo 07 punto
com
en el 94 si no me equivoco
lo vendió en 900 millones de dólares el
y es uno de nuestros grandes amigos que
nos dan muchos consejos la última
versión de ultra casas que la reviso
como hace unos cuatro meses y sus
palabras textuales fueron que en
tecnología y usabilidad era de los
mejores portales que había visto en el
mundo
lo que les quiero decir con esto es no
hablar de lo que el fracaso se está
haciendo sino de demostrar que en
bolivia podemos hacer lo mismo que está
haciendo fuera es lo que les quiero
inculcar básicamente
todo ha sido gracias a 27 genios que hoy
día son otro grupo y estamos creciendo
un poco más hoy en nuestras casas tiene
25 mil propiedades en oferta tiene 170
mil usuarios registrados generamos 60
mil potenciales transacciones
inmobiliarias al mes 60 mil
conversaciones entre un comprador y un
vendedor al mes y hemos logrado levantar
una ronda de aproximadamente medio
millón de dólares que nos hace el estar
a digital que ha levantado la mayor de
la historia en bolivia eso nos
enorgullece muchísimo
hemos logrado que inversionistas
profesionales del extranjero porque en
bolivia no existían se ofician en
bolivia y decidan invertir
ya con la experiencia de otra casa su
otra casa genera una gran cantidad de
delitos para hipotecas créditos de
vivienda
entonces originalmente trabajamos con un
solo banco y decidimos que en vez de
trabajar con un solo banco y un solo
crédito vamos a ampliar vamos a trabajar
con múltiples bancos y múltiples
créditos y lanzamos 13 créditos puntocom
ultra que sostiene 8 bancos que ofertan
créditos cinco tipos de crédito en ocho
meses dado que ya no teníamos que pasar
ese año y medio de no saber nada y ya
sabíamos un poco más hemos logrado
30.000 solicitudes crediticias que
equivalen a 700 millones de dólares esto
todo en bolivia
estamos explorando nuevas tecnologías de
seis meses que le vamos a lanzar
esperamos en noviembre o diciembre en
bolivia y en el primer cuarto del 2019
en méxico apuntamos a ser el primer
estado boliviano que no solo o no se
enfoca en desarrollar software sino
queremos sobre una solución queremos
ojalá que mañana mexicanos chilenos
brasileros utilicen una solución
boliviana ese es nuestro sueños es
nuestra nuestro objetivo y ya se halla
vamos a ir con mucha fuerza entonces
todo esto se los resumo en una hipótesis
que yo tengo volviendo a lo que
previamente le estaba comentando
cuando hablamos de producir computadoras
celulares refrigeradores automóviles
porque no podemos hacerlo y yo lo
simplificó en tres ceros uno es normal
el otro es equipamiento especializado y
otros son procesos cuando tú quieres
hacer un automóvil necesita es pero
enojado enorme y no sólo unas cuantas
personas sino son miles de personas que
tienen que saber exactamente dónde va el
tornillo dónde va etcétera etcétera
procesos muy complejos donde los has ido
mejorando año tras año como las de
toyota como lo ha hecho apple etcétera
etcétera y maquinaria muy sofisticada y
muy costosa es por eso que en bolivia
les soy franco y en argentina y en
brasil yo dudo mucho que algún día
podamos producir celulares
creo que en claro el cliente no pensamos
algún tipos hemos perdido una gran
cantidad de plata desarrollando
computadoras y celulares y no hemos sido
competitivos en absoluto con un monstruo
como es actual
hablemos de tecnología
tecnología no necesitas tanto tecnología
necesitas know-how nada más en digital y
ese know-how es más conceptual no es
especializado y no necesitas que 20 mil
personas lo sepan necesitas que 20
personas lo sepan entonces claramente
percibo de que es muy difícil que
bolivia mañana desarrollo automóviles y
manejaremos automóviles bolivianos pero
si podemos hacer una honesta hora
digital como lo es mercadolibre como lo
es rap y en el mundo y mañana podremos
tener una empresa que valga tres veces
lo que vale pero de jim verde estemos
moviendo la economía en bolivia
en bolivia tenemos talento lo que está
súper claro capacidad super claro lo que
no tenemos es un ojal y lo que no
tenemos es inversión
entonces cómo solucionamos esto les voy
a contar un poco lo que hacen nuestros
sabios del frente en chile en 10 años el
gobierno chileno a través de corfo ha
invertido 900 millones de dólares en
historias
de estos 900 millones de dólares 90 han
sido en su aceleradora incubadora estado
chile que hoy en día es de las más
importantes regionales
qué quiere decir esto el gobierno
chileno se ha dado cuenta que tienen una
oportunidad
que probablemente no vamos a dejar
nuevamente un auto chileno pero si
podemos tener una historia chileno que
valga 30.000 millones de dólares en el
futuro y los está invirtiendo y yo les
digo que hay más de un estrato en chile
equivale más de 100 millones en este
momento y no se sorprendan si en el
corto plazo empezamos a ver este tipo de
cosas pues creo que es algo importante
para evaluar probablemente tenemos una
oportunidad pública de que no estamos
explotando de verdad probablemente
estamos invirtiendo en lugares donde no
deberíamos invertir o metiéndonos en
lugares donde no vamos a ganar otra cosa
que es importante chile utiliza
metodologías de stanford no es inventado
la metodología pero el lugar donde mejor
se hacen las cosas para este tipo de
temas y está tomando esa metodología son
pequeños tips que creo que podrán hacer
clic en las cosas para nosotros
por último
estamos acostumbrados a consumir
consumimos todo lo que nos traen de
afuera y no es la diferencia entre más
digitales consumimos über visitas y
pedidos ya facebook whatsapp y lo que
venga lo vamos a seguir consumiendo creo
que es hora de enfocarnos en que
nosotros podemos desarrollar algo que
otros no consuman aquí está bien
nuestros jóvenes está la esperanza de
que nosotros podamos desarrollar el
siguiente mercado libre boliviano y
poder ser como estonia un país
sofisticado en este tema competitivo a
nivel mundial y poder realmente dejar
una marca dejar una huella y hacer que
nuestra economía en verdad crezca y
dejemos de ser un país pobre
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]